sky news has been reporting on an energy
supply crisis all week energy firms
going out of business rocketing prices
but in the context of climate change are
high gas prices a good thing and kyla
i'm just going to take a look at what
quasi quattang has said our exposure to
volatile global gas prices underscores
the importance uh there of a strong
homegrown renewable energy sector so
what's bad for consumers now michaela
could this could be a good in terms of
renewable energy and the planet
i'm i'm hesitant to say this is this is
a good thing that is happening right now
but what i will say is it's bringing
attention to the fact that um gas is
unsustainable um financially but also
obviously for the planet and what we
actually need to be doing is moving
towards a renewable economy that
actually will be there for the future is
sustainable for the future but also
won't have these same fluctuations in
prices and will be better for all of us
but do we not need a gas tom to switch
it on when wind lets us down or the sun
lets us down
we can develop a an energy system that
doesn't need gas at all and in fact if
what we'd done was what we could have
done in insulating the leakiest homes in
europe and deploying the renewables that
we've got faster than what we've done
not only would we have driven people's
bills down rather than putting them up
but we would reduce our vulnerability to
these kind of price spikes caused by
international resource markets so in a
sense the real signal from this
is to get on with what we know we can do
to reduce our vulnerability both to the
climate and to high energy prices it's a
huge job though isn't it michaela so
many of our houses are powered by gas
aren't they
yeah but i also think that there's a
huge like opportunity that we have here
to realize the necessity and kind of
immediacy of our need to invest in these
um renewables instead and create a green
economy where we don't have this
reliance on such um fragile industries
as the gas industry we know that this is
a declining industry we've known that
for such a long time and we need to be
moving away from that and i think that
we can see this as an opportunity to
really take that on board and actually
mean that all of us can actually access
um energy that is not unstable is
sustainable and is safe and better for
all of us we must leave it there but i
can see you're dying to say something
tom very in 10 seconds
yeah
anna's right opportunity is a better
driver of change than punishment